um let's go to danny in fort worth texas
danny what's up my man
hey john how you doing outstanding how
are you i'm great thanks for taking some
time to talk to me this is uh
this is awesome so i listen to you guys
all the time thank you very much well
thank you it's awesome for me too how
can i help this morning yeah i want to
try and be brief so i'm summarizing a
year's worth of history and a lot of
stuff that has
uh bottled up over the last year but uh
the straw that broke
camels back this most recent weekend as
my dad completely disrespected my wife
in our home
and that's a tough one for me and for a
multitude of reasons but at the end of
the day i have to pick my wife
so um hey can we stop there can we stop
there for a second
sure good for you my man thank you hey
listen
i'm being serious and i'm looking
directly in this camera and i know
you're listening to me right now you
can't see me
good for you that's the right decision
we're supposed to respect our parents
but people do not respect disrespect our
spouses in our homes good for you
okay continue all right so over the last
year we have uh
i'm one of four children okay um
three of my siblings all have kids as
well
my three boys my wife and i felt are not
treated with the same
uh priority as the rest of the kids okay
they were grandkids i should say
so i've had our parents over my parents
over twice in the last year to directly
confront them about it and and gave them
plenty of warnings that hey we'd like to
have you guys over to our home to talk
about these things we've done that twice
okay
uh both times no there was no real
animosity no
issues nothing was going on from my
parents as far as we could tell
everything seemed to be fine
and then this last weekend oh i should
back up a little bit they they even went
about two or three weeks ago and said it
just completely surprised us
showed up at our house at about 8 30 in
the on a sunday morning with donuts for
all the grandkids it was a huge
huge effort phenomenal it's great for us
so we thought okay water's under the
bridge everything's fine
and then my uh my youngest son turned
one
just we had his big big birthday i
thought it was a college graduation with
how much my wife played
into it but it was great
my dad comes in doesn't say that i say
hi to him and stuff like that he doesn't
say a word to my wife
the entire time we're there deliberately
uh walks avoids her doesn't won't talk
to her
um she starts to notice it more and more
throughout the day and says hey did i do
something to upset your dad ask me a
couple questions so i start looking at
it listen
kind of being like well you know maybe
she's just overreacting or missing
something or maybe he's off or something
like that so i tried to look at it
and uh sure enough he'd write him and i
intently watched
multiple potential interactions where he
uh
avoided her to the point of
you know they passed by each other he'd
intentionally look the opposite
direction things like that
yeah um so then i let the party go on
uh everything's fine next day there's
some other issues with my siblings that
we were that i was also addressing
but uh not to get into that here i set
up i opened up a group text
to my dad my mom and my siblings i said
hey guys there's some issues i wanted to
talk to you guys individually about
but um my wife felt extremely
disrespected
in our house and i don't i don't
appreciate that
and i specifically called my dad out in
that i said dad i
would expect i'm frustrated to see
your leadership in our family
and think that it's okay to treat my
wife with disrespect because i know it
would be okay for me to treat
your wife with disrespect in your home
um
and kyle called some of the specific
stuff out well
to me and
basically his well his exact response
was
um i was not once acknowledged
all night long even with a hello until i
said goodbye
keep dumping on us and place blame on us
where
we are okay with that some things need
to be figured out and we will not be the
ones to point it out i will not respond
yep um so again i didn't want to do it
all through text messages like
in my message i said i would like to
address these things individually
one-on-one
sure but these are this is kind of where
i'm at what his text message community
said
um is that yes we do have issues
even though you've come over twice and
told us no we don't and she started it
so i'm not going to respond
or something to that effect right she
started it she disrespected me first so
it's okay for me to disrespect her
on top of that his response sets a
precedence
in front of my siblings that it's okay
to treat my wife that way
and so let me make sure i'm clear here
when you say disrespected my wife
he didn't call her names he didn't laugh
in her face
he he he essentially ignored her during
an event at your home
is that right yes and so then i asked
him why
in in in his response he's he's directly
saying
well she did it to me first well that's
how i interpret she didn't acknowledge
me once
so i didn't acknowledge her and i'm just
going to completely
but there's there's history there
already sure with stuff like this has
happened
before so and that's his way of of
um pouting i don't know how to put it
yeah
maybe that's a little rough no dude men
pout all the time i
i've done that before um that's that's a
way that
that men can non and non-abusively take
power over a room is by hovering with
their pouting
right that's a powerful dude move
um so let me challenge you on some
things
before we dig into your old man okay yep
who has made you the
the home quarterback or i would call the
the moral character quarterback of your
house it seems like you
are on prowl for
like you're going to make sure you talk
to your brothers and sisters about
things you're going to talk to your mom
and dad about things you're going to
have these talks
who anointed you and that's that's a
loaded word i know who anointed you
the character and morality police of
your family unit
yeah that's a really good question i
don't i don't think anybody
has that necessarily or has given me
that i think maybe i
appointed myself okay okay um i don't
not that i
intentionally meant to when you put it
that way but yeah so
the second thing is is you mention this
but i just got to say dude
the worst thing you can possibly do ever
is to address your entire family
on issues of character
frustration about your wife
via text message right because everybody
hears those things differently and
as you're telling the story i understand
there's years of history that i'm not
privy to but i wonder if
my son and his wife called me over and
said the way you're treating your
grandkids
isn't right it's not fair here's five
reasons why you're treating them
differently than you're treating
my brothers and sisters kids and then
nothing changes and then i get another
lecture from my son
about how i'm not grandparenting in a
way that he sees fit
and then i try i reach out and i bring
donuts i'm trying now i'm now i'm going
over i'm i'm going okay we're going to
be hyper intentional about this
nothing says i love you like a box of
carbs and sugar right
especially for kids and then i
show up i'm on high alert i want to be
present
i don't want to speak when with in say
wrong things i don't want to
look the wrong ways i want to be fully
in
and then i walk in and i just happen to
walk past
my daughter-in-law and she's busy and
she doesn't acknowledge me
and so i my initial thought is oh did i
do something wrong again
i'm on the defensive now because they've
already called me over their house and
lectured me twice
these kids that are half my age and half
my wisdom have lectured me twice
i don't know what to do with this deal
and so i'm going to pass her a few times
and make sure she sees me make sure she
knows i'm here
and she ignores me twice well now i'm
going to be
i'm get my inner child is going to come
out i'm going to act like a baby and
if you're going to ignore me then i'm
going to ignore you right but i'm just
wondering if these are grown-ups acting
like children in this
environment everyone's going to point a
finger at each other
you're the guy that keeps calling folks
over to lecture them on how they need to
be better brothers and sisters and
parents and grandparents that just
sounds like a lot of heat man
and i'm wondering if there's a way that
nobody can win in this deal
unless they do it exactly like danny
wants it done
for our kids for my wife i don't see it
as a
like as if your brothers and sisters
know your dad is a powder
and he acts like a baby i don't see that
as
a free license to now they can
disrespect your wife
i don't see it that way at all if your
brothers and sisters know that about
your old man they know that about your
old man right and if they know you're
the lecturer then they know that about
you too
um and even if i have a license to
disrespect somebody's wife who i love
i'm not going to because i'm a person a
character right and hopefully they're
that same way too
but it sounds like you are on high
high offense alert where does that come
from
yeah so um like the justice police like
you are
ready to yeah no you're to fight you're
right you're absolutely
right and i didn't and it's great
perspective and i definitely haven't
thought of it that way
where does that come from though because
it comes from probably a good place that
your sense of justice comes from a good
place
where where is that from i i think
that's from a long history of
i was expected to
growing up i mean i was not allowed to
make mistakes i wasn't allowed to not
say hi to somebody when you walk in
their house i wasn't allowed to
i mean i know i mean to the point where
we uh
in significant trouble whatever that
looked like right grounded or
sure publicly and you know whatever
so and then that
um the i'll say that the
how do i word this the uh parenting
style
my parents have changed significantly
from my older sister and i
to my younger brother and sister who is
specifically that the two that i'm
addressing here so maybe it's just this
feeling of
um and this this is a horrible way of
working it but maybe it's a feeling of
moral superiority
which is not true yep um it feels like a
uh like a fraternity we had to do it so
you have to do it
and you all didn't have it y'all didn't
have it as hard as we had it and so
you're never
really gonna be true brothers because we
got branded and hit in the face with
bricks and y'all just got to right that
kind of thing
yep yeah um so that's that's part of it
now the other piece of it
uh is probably some emotional response
on my part because my wife
uh tries so hard to include everybody
sure and
and to bring everybody over there and
it's affecting she's starting to wonder
what am i doing wrong
and we've we have had them over twice
and we have asked them and they keep
saying nothing and then my dad's
response
kind of sounded like well there is
something wrong but we're not going to
point it out sure
and i was like well thanks for your help
i guess right i mean um or
for not helping and so it was affecting
the way my wife felt about herself and
the way she um
she she's crying to me and saying why am
i
not good enough for your family kind of
thing there you go
right and for the and for the last year
i've been telling her
a year and a half hey if we'll just make
the effort here i know my family they
will respond
and you will be welcomed with open arms
and love and kindness and it just hasn't
been the case
there you go and so there's probably
some frustration there for me as well
and i want to tell you i want to affirm
that frustration
if anybody's mean or disrespectful to my
wife if they ignore my wife if they're
ugly to her
man my defenses go up my emotions go up
my desire to seek justice on her behalf
goes up
that makes you somebody who cares about
your wife right so here's
here's a perspective i want to give to
you
okay number one
stop being the justice morality police
for the people who love you and people
who are around you
it's exhausting for them and more
importantly it's exhausting for you
yep and you are wearing yourself out
psychologically spiritually emotionally
and you're wearing out the most
important deepest threaded relationships
in your life
honestly for not a lot of reason and
here i'm going to tell you why
that leads me to number two you've got
to take
your family members out of your box
and i've got a youtube rant on this
but at the end of the day you should
have four or five people in your life
that you allow to hurt your feelings
that you allow
you choose who hurts your feelings you
choose who quote unquote gets a vote
into your life
you love your wife and you love your
kids and you think they are awesome
and they probably are they might not be
but they probably
are right right right at the end of the
day
other people don't have to see it that
way and if you choose to
set off every time somebody doesn't see
it that way
you're just going to scorch earth around
you you're going to end up with a pile
of bodies yours included and that's a
waste of that's a waste of a joyful life
and so i would take my dad out of the
box you've sat him down and talked to
him
right you have talked to your mom and
said here's how we want we would like
y'all to show appreciation for our
children
and they are communicating through their
actions no
and you can continue to go to war with
that or you can say
great that's how they choose to live the
people i want in my life are going to
honor my kids
and my wife in a certain way so i'm
taking my parents out of that box
am i going to be mature and respect them
of course am i going to invite them to
birthday parties
yup and i'm also going to tell my wife
and we're going to have this
conversation with her
they don't have permission to hurt your
feelings anymore there's nothing you can
do to make them
be different they are who they are your
dad's probably
been had bouts of immaturity through
your entire childhood
and then he probably tried to
overcorrect with your younger two
siblings
and be the cool dad who just let stuff
was cool and cool and cool
and that he probably found different
connection with them than he did with
you guys and probably treat your kids
differently as a result
it is what it is what it is what you are
what you are choosing to do is let your
character be defined by somebody else's
actions
no that's good you are responsible for
your character
you are responsible for modeling what a
dad looks like to your your young kids
okay and so i want you to own
your heart your home and that's it and
if your brothers and sisters are jerks
to you then they're not invited
they're just not and that's not any skin
off your back
it's not any skin off it's not a
testament to your wife's role as
how good of a job she's doing it just is
and all of us have people in our
families that come to birthday parties
and act differently than we probably
wish they would
and we can choose to invite them or not
and then we're going to just know what
we're getting right we're just going to
note we're getting we're going to move
on i'm not going to spend the emotional
and physical energy trying to change
other people
and that man i'm telling you right now
you are setting yourself
up for a life of lightness a life of joy
in my family my wife actually sends an
email to my family
and they will say here's when we're
going to be in town here's what i want
to do for dinner here's what i want to
do after dinner
we're bringing games we're going to go
for walks the guys are going to go out
into the woods whatever's happening
and she sets an agenda and it's awesome
the whole family's like okay sweet cool
and right we will say we are not going
to talk about politics this year that's
going to be a
a family deal and my family knows i will
get up and walk out the door
and i love them but i'm not going to
subject myself
and my family and my love my beloved
relationships to fights
especially when we only get to see each
other a few times a year i'm not gonna
do it and so we're not gonna talk about
politics we're gonna talk about other
things we've got plenty of other stuff
to talk about
and so it's just setting those
boundaries in yourself and being okay
with it talking to your wife and letting
her know that she is not
on probationary status here she is not
at a tryout
she is loving her kids the best way she
knows how she's loving you the best way
she knows how
and some people just aren't going to
like that and that is their problem
not y'alls is that fair do you get what
i'm saying no no i totally
get what you're saying um so i see a
counselor on my own
yeah she always helps me um
talks me off the ledge so to speak like
you are here okay
where um our emotions
cloud our reason our logic
and so um no this has been phenomenal uh
i really appreciate it
your question is this going to be on the
podcast here shortly yeah yeah
yeah it'll be launched sometime yeah um
yeah
do me a favor the next time
your dad does something or your mom does
something or your brothers and sisters
do something
and it immediately sets your feelings
off it immediately sets your emotions
off
before you say anything write them down
and then i want you to look at the
feelings you've written down
and demand evidence from them
so for instance i got you your wife is
going to pull you aside and say dad's
ignoring me
he is completely disrespecting me and
you're gonna see it happen
and you're gonna write down you're gonna
get you're gonna get instantly pissed
off and you're gonna write it down
dad's ignoring my wife which leads to
dad's disrespecting my wife which is
gonna lead to
dad and you're going to fill in the
blank on what's wrong with that
and at that moment i want you to get out
of your dad's head because you don't
know what's going on in there
he might be trying to tiptoe his way
through a party
to honor you honor her and he's just
doing a crappy job at it
and he might be trying to just be a
complete jerk and act like a
two-year-old
and he might have 50 other things go on
he might be not feeling good
and trying right and so after this call
i want you to not text not
electronically communicate
i want you to call your brothers and
sisters who are on that text
and say look y'all are grown-ups i'm a
grown-up i should not have texted you
guys i'm sorry i am not your parents
i'm not your moral police i'm just
trying to get everybody to love each
other and i screwed this up and i'm
sorry
and i want you to not explain just let
that be
and they may say yeah that's right you
suck take it just take it
i'm sorry you're right and i want you to
call your old man
i want you to call your old man and say
dude
i don't know what got into me i'm your
son
i don't have any business lecturing you
guys i know you love our grandkids i
know you love me i know you love your
wife
i was out of line i'm sorry and then let
it go
and if your dad wants to talk to you
after that which he might he might not
cool
let it go just like frozen one
and not frozen two not holding back
anymore let it go
let it go right um but call them and
apologize call your mom and say dude i
don't know what i was in
in my head i'm your son i'm lecturing my
parents that's not cool
i'm out i'm not doing that anymore y'all
are doing the best you can i appreciate
you
and then you and your wife get in a room
and decide
what are we to get our feelings heard
over and what are we not going to get
our feelings heard over who we're going
to let hurt our feelings and who are not
going to let our feelings
let hurt our feelings and then move on
then let it
go all right danny you are uh i'm so
grateful for the call
appreciate your heart appreciate you
being a guy who's trying to get it right
trying to care about people
but is also trying to wrestle hard with
his feelings and emotions you're a good
man
and i appreciate you call me back after
you call your family and apologize i
want to hear how those go
we'll have you back on the show i want
to hear how that goes can't wait